you wrote that beautiful
is what you intensely pay attention to
even a cockroach is beautiful if you
look very closely
can you expand on this what is beauty
so
what i'm i wrote here actually
corresponds to my subjective experience
that i had
through extended periods of meditation
it's it's pretty crazy that at some
point the meditation gets you to the
place that you have really
increased
focus increase attention and then you
look at the very simple objects that
were all the time around you can look at
the table or on the pen or at that
nature
and
you notice more and more details
and it becomes very pleasant to look at
it
and it once again it kind of reminds me
my childhood
like i just pure joy
of being
it's also i have seen even the reverse
effect that
by default regardless of what we possess
we very quickly get used to it
and you know you can have a very
beautiful house
and uh if you don't put sufficient
effort
you're just gonna get used to it
and it doesn't bring any more joy
regardless of what you have
yeah
well i actually uh
i find that material possessions
get in the way of that experience of
pure joy
so i've always i've been very fortunate
to just find joy in simple things just
just like you're saying
just like i don't know objects in my
life just stupid objects like this cup
like thing you know just objects sounds
okay i'm not being eloquent but
literally objects in the world
they're just full of joy because it's
like
i can't believe
one i can't believe uh that i'm
fortunate enough to be alive to
experience these objects and then two i
can't believe
humans are clever enough to have built
these objects
the the hierarchy of pleasure that that
provides is infinite i mean even if you
look at the cup of water so you know you
see first like a level of like a
reflection of light but then you think
you know man there's like a trillions
upon of trillions of uh particles
bouncing uh
against each other there is also uh the
the tension on the surface that you know
if the back back could like a stand on
it and move around and you think it also
has this like a magical property that as
you decrease temperature
it actually expands in volume which
allows for the
you know legs to freeze on the on the
surface and then at the bottom to have
actually uh not freeze which allows for
life like a
crazy yeah you look
in detail at some object and you think
actually you know this table
that was just the figment of someone's
imagination at some point and then there
was like thousands of people involved to
actually manufacture it yeah and put it
here and by default no one cares
[Laughter]
and then you can start thinking about
evolution how it all started from single
cell organisms
that led to this table and and okay
these thoughts they give me life
appreciation yeah and
and even lack of those just the pure raw
signal also gives their life
appreciation see the thing is
and then that's coupled
uh for me with the sadness that the
whole ride ends
and perhaps is deeply coupled in that
the fact that this experience this
moment ends
gives it
gives it an intensity that i'm not sure
i would otherwise have
so in that same way i try to meditate on
my own death often
you